مثلما يحدث كل عام يشهد السودان اعتبارا
من مطلع مايو هطولا مطريا غزيرا لكن امطار
العام 2020 كانت غزيره ومستمره لتسبب
كارثه انسانيه كبرى لم يسلم منها بشر ولا
حجر تاركه البلاد في حاله يرثى لها فماذا
حدث في اوائل سبتمبر تعرض السودان لسلسله
هطول مطري تسبب في ارتفاع منسوب مياه نهر
النيل وبعض الروافد لدرجات قياسيه بلغت 17
مترا وثمانيه وخمسين سنتيمترا في اعلى
مستوى مسجل منذ اكثر من قرن خلال ايام
قليله اجتاحت الفيضانات البلاد وامتدت
اثارها لسته عشره ولايه من اصل ثمانيه
عشره كان اكثرها تضررا ولايه الخرطوم
والمجتمعات الواقعه على طول النيل الازرق
ما دفع البلاد لاعلان حاله الطوارئ لمده
ثلاثه اشهر حملت المياه الهائجه معها كل
ما وجدته في طريقها اقتلعت الاشجار دمرت
المحاصيل واغرقت المزارع وعمت الفوضى بين
السكان شوهد كثيرون وهم يحاولون عبور
السيول منهم من حمل ابناءه ومنهم من جمع
حاجياته استعدادا للمغادره فيما لقي 121
شخصا حتفهم
تقطعت السبل بالمجتمعات المحليه ونفقت
الحيوانات في الحقول وامتلات المدارس التي
كان من المقرر افتتاحها بعد اسبوع
بالمشردين ونزح 481 الفا من منازلهم حيث
دمر اكثر من 100 الف منزل
وهدا نهر النيل مع مرور ايام سبتمبر
الكارثيه لكن تاثيراتها القت بظلالها على
ما لا يقل عن مليون شخص كما تفاقمت
الازمات الانسانيه في البلاد فع لى اثر
الكارثه التي تم تصنيفها بانها الاعلى منذ
فيضانات عام
1902 قدرت التكلفه المتوقعه للاستجابه
الانسانيه السنويه ذلك العام بنحو مليار
و600 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]